I'm in a Perpetual state of
recalibration and I like that I like re
rebuilding the engine coming and that's
a new act over here year to year and
then it's a
Tools in Your Arsenal on how to be
you know more compassionate more
empathetic uh just a better version of
yourself so it's kind of a constant uh
you know state of uh forward progression
in in personal and professional how many
therapists do you have simultaneously
I got one good one I actually got one
right out of the gate it only took us
about a year and a half for me to be
very honest
that's not bad actually you know you sit
down you think why should I tell you
stranger everything about me like you
know it's it's it's hard to be able to
just let go and go to that space so I
actually think a year and a half for
being really honest is not too bad but I
get like fixated on getting to the truth
of whatever it is that I eat if it's a
script if it's a you know Comedy Tour if
it's even just you know in my office and
in writing I'm always trying to get to
like the real nitty-gritty of like what
am I about what is this really about why
am I doing it stop it we're like so much
more similar than I was expecting okay
good like are you talking about your
journey that's my life are you in the
green are you in the red are you where
are you at yeah I'm in the green right
now getting to the point where like you
get past the initial phase of feeling
like it's all really hard and you're
like wait this Journeys feels worse most
of the time than it feels good like the
ratio's off
once you get past the initial hump then
it's actually like a better Baseline all
the time and getting to the point now
where I am asking myself the question
what's my part in this every time no
matter what and then being able to see
things from an observer perspective and
how quickly you're able to
um the mechanics uh what do they call it
in working out like the impact rep that
impact rep how do I respond here and how
quickly you can realize I'm not going to
go there the the old way of doing it and
here's the healthier better hopefully
more outstanding version of myself
showing up here to help me through what
was your what was your Arc like well so
the first part of my life I was an
introvert I was self-loathing I had a
lot of fear I came from a phobic mother
I came from an alcoholic father who was
very very brilliant decent guy until uh
the drinking
so I described the first part of my life
is not only was I
um off kilter but I not not realizing
from an alcoholic home that I lived on a
tilt you know you live skewed and
constantly not sure how to balance
um so all of those things when I finally
hit stand up and found purpose and this
thing that I I loved the first part of
my life it was never about me and I was
like why can't anything be about me I'm
scared I'm nobody wants to include me I
feel lost I feel I'm an introvert and
then years later it's like it all became
about me
and so I was building all those voids
from who I came from and not really
realizing that was all just kind of uh
Superfluous of course I'm fast tracking
and I'm skipping a lot but I think at
the heart of your question it's like I I
didn't know how to be present for a long
time in my life I was either running
from the kid that I didn't like of
myself or I was running to the next
um Mountain that I was I was succeeding
if I have another Mountain then I don't
need to look back right I'm I'm in it to
win it so it took me a minute to finally
understand like what real Zen was in
balance and the truth which is also you
saying that like I
I've said many times that but that this
life is about me just figuring out the
truth of everything like what's the
nature of this reality what's the nature
of me what am I really here for what's
how am I best serving yeah how am I how
am I broken and how is how is that okay
and then what does that mean for how
like I uh intercept other people's pain
and then how do I give people my power
and share truly what I'm all about
have you figured that part out
you know
I I I understand it I have a better you
know I
I am a flawed person I have a lot to
share and a lot of ability and things
that I have discovered that I love about
life and about myself but I also know in
it I can at least identify the places
that I didn't have boundaries and where
for a long time I let people just Pummel
me dude I mean like I didn't even know
boundaries really meant no everybody was
invited for a while it was like You Like
Me Now oh everybody there was no mindful
thoughtful compassionate collaborative
caring as I talk about now in my
stand-up and I have kind of jokes about
my therapy sneaks into my act because I
always want to find the laugh but
there's so many things that have
enriched my life that ends up as fodder
for the stand up but those five things
that you know mindfulness did not yeah
that came late to the party for me like
mindfulness of yourself mindfulness of
your
surroundings like go more into that one
yeah looking at the relationships that I
had and having to do diligence and take
the take the time and look for the
necessary traits and emotional you know
values that that a good person maybe at
a great place in their their life is
going to be able to hang with you and it
isn't about drama and it's not about
taking anything away from anybody who
are the people that kind of like are
also in that Zen comfortable place or at
least in the place of like doing the
work and realizing I too have my you
know flaws and issues and those people I
can hang with all day if you bring me
the worst truth I I love you
if you if you put on a game face and a
facade and it's still awesome I don't I
don't want to be around that I don't
care how great it feels to be around a a
faux version of you I want the ugly
truth of somebody so that I can feel
like well I can tell you some things
about me that like I'm still in a work
in progress on do you feel like that you
um gave a lot of time and energy to
people that were manipulative or brought
you down it is Hollywood so yes uh you
kind of sign up for I wish there was
like a real you know definitive mission
statement of like show up here and get
ready because it's you know all the the
ten thousand hours and the things that
you hear you know from great seminars or
I used to go to AAA meetings with my
friends after gigs because I I've never
drank I've never had a drink in my life
but I loved going to support friends but
I learned so much and I again I liked I
liked that there was a a proof even
though it was Stark and really hard
sometimes to be in those rooms I found
myself really it was alluring because I
was like I want to be this real I want
to admit some of these things about
myself that like that are you know kind
of like boiling inside of me that I'm
unsure about so I think that when I got
to this this industry
and then I made it it was like the
undertow for a while I I really didn't
know what end was up because the
community when you're the bell of the
ball has a real way of making it feel
like you're important forever
you know yeah so you come back down to
earth and then you start to go like okay
we're you know what is real life here
what am I truly what what brings me
happiness day to day and not the big
mountain that I think I'm gonna always
jump over because you're just constantly
jumping from dopamine hit to dopamine
hit
and I think because I do I'm one of
those people I subscribe a lot to like
the the child inside and how we're you
know formulated from so many of our
early surroundings and I had a I had a
mom opposite to my dad who was
unfortunately self-defeating and then
would drink my Maham would quite
literally say things like um knowing I
was insecure right knowing that I'm
that I'm having trouble like social
anxiety she would say things like uh
every night when you know I'd be going
to bed she'd come in and say good night
and I'd say mom what if I want to be a
baker and she would say you will be the
best baker in the world your bakery will
be renowned you will have people
visiting from around the world the next
night Mom what if I wanted to be like
have heists what if I wanted she'd say
you would be the best big robber you
would come up and she she wanted to
build me up because I was so the
opposite that when I said I'm going to
be a stand-up comedian I was 15 and she
said I knew from when you were very
little
that you're going to do something really
special and that you are going to make
people happy even though you feel
unhappy a lot you'll understand how
important it is to have that happiness
in your life it was true I loved comedy
I love when my family was funny because
it kept us away from the the dark stuff
but for me
my communication my My love language was
humor that was it and so she made me
believe that yeah there's a mountain of
course any mountain you could always
that's yours take it it took me a long
time to realize that's also the
messaging it was like I love my mom was
my compass I would not be here without
her the most incredible energy that I
could have ever asked for in my life was
my mom and yet
I think her own fears phobias things
that she missed out on and then seeing
me and realizing I just don't want him
to have that thing that I have I want
him to shoot for the moon you know she
she didn't because she didn't shoot for
the moon or she was just trying to fill
in the gaps for you like a good mom to
be able to yeah I think I think Danica
with my mom it was it was fascinating
because I was watching Oprah one time I
was like a mama's boy I come home from
school we watch Oprah and I remember my
mom what time the uh the Radio City
Rockettes were on
and they're all kick in and do you know
beautiful outfits and the the whole you
know shebang and my mom started to cry
my mom by the way was a love dancing and
my mom had beautiful legs like long the
longest Gams as she would say yeah and
she was weeping
I said Mom what's what's the matter and
she said I feel like I could have done
something beautiful like this I wish
that I had done something like this I
feel like when I see people like these
people I'm drawn to that and I'm I feel
like I missed out
and it was interesting because not only
in that moment was I like well you're an
incredible mother and I'm trying to talk
her up as a son the best I can at 13 or
14. but I was watching Saturday Night
Live those same Saturday nights watching
uh Martin Short on there doing skits and
killing and saying I want to be there I
want to stand with those people I don't
know who those people are they feel like
they'd like me they feel like they would
accept me and I had the same thing as my
mom but I wasn't going to not see it
through even if it didn't work I was
gonna go as far to my radio city as I
possibly could if you like this clip
whole episode
click at the bottom of your screen